let's talk about some of the positions
that you've taken you were short valiant
you have covered that position now was
it because of the restatement the 58
million dollars that changed your view
no I covered valiant beforehand there's
a lot that is uncertain with the company
and at these prices right here I'd
rather be in situations that I have more
certainty
I think the Restatement is the start of
a longer process I like the fact that
now the public discourse about valiant
is out there I thought Wells Fargo did a
terrific job and covering the risks
associated with the company but as an
investor right now I find the stock
uninvested on the long side and at the
same time I didn't find the complete
risk reward on the short side notice my
report put a $50 price target stock got
the 68 that was from 150 pretty darn
close if that's the case I think you
know sometimes you take your money and
you move on speaking of price targets
you gave one for a monster a couple of
weeks ago I think an $80 price target
it's trading at 120 and change why why
the I mean you're obviously bearish
monster and you've taken a short
position in us why I think Monster is a
it's a fine company if you put aside all
the risks involved with energy drinks
Monster has been executing they've done
a terrific job executing and we saw
yesterday they're actually buying
someone in their supply chain so
traditionally when you do something by
someone in your supply chain you're
actually admitting to the fact that
you're a more mature company that maybe
you're your larger growth might be
behind you and now you're more concerned
about keeping the cost together so that
being said I just think Monster should
be more valued like any other beverage
company that has equal competition to it
and that would put that at a
considerably lower price and I said in
the market that valuations matter so
maybe in a market today where we take
sex monster swings monster in the market
valuations won't matter but pretty soon
when valuations do start counting in
this market I think Monster has some
downside risk to it yeah your report is
just a little bit more
you know vocal them that a little bit
more hefty used to talk about months for
going into China and saying it basically
doesn't have a chance yet there are 15
analyst on Wall Street ten of them at
buys and five have holds and one of them
says you know at least one of them says
that the China story is where monster
will see the upside it is completely and
utterly ridiculous monster I'm going to
give credit to monster management and
saying they're bright people and let's
also give credit to understand that
China did not exist as a consumer market
in the past one or two years
I think monster might be the only
consumer discretionary product on the
S&P 500 that is not sold in China so
first you have to worry about getting a
license in China second you have to
worry about the costs of selling in
China meaning you're not selling a can
for three dollars and 50 cents like Red
Bull has a complete different type of
red bull that they do sell in China and
then you have to worry about making a
complete brand what Monster Energy is
it's a brand so they sell you a
lifestyle in the can pretty much no one
says oh I drink monster because it
tastes so good
but you associate yourself with the
brand I just want to know there's a lot
of cross going to bring it monster eyes
that what I'm just saying is this don't
listen to me listen to management
management hasn't been to China in 19
years or monster's been around for maybe
12 years if they haven't been there
there's a reason why well you don't wake
up today go maybe we should go to China
alright but we haven't heard from
monster and we are trying to getting to
contact these companies a monster would
say that coca-cola has been to China and
there's a very much of an overlap
between the distribution of both
companies at the moment let's move on to
another a short position that you've
taken out fairly recently would you like
to tell us what it is okay well we will
have a few we saw mobile I reported
earnings today and the stock opened
lower but with the rest of the retinas
that could went higher I called mobile I
at one point my short fur of the year
for 2016
I think mobilizes comfortable of as
short as you can have without ever
getting inside information this is
pretty much as good as management will
tell you when you look at it management
that can't sell enough stock and
dedicating any money to research and
development are brought up this case
earlier last year and Midway and in late
last year and then management at the
conference call today management said I
think we're gonna dedicate more research
more money to R&D what's on that you're
actually shorting gap as well I just
want to ask you why you're shorting gap
short interesting gap is rising that's
why I'm sure well right now I'm short
gap stores I just think in this way it's
complete become completely irrelevant if
you look at everything that has come out
all of the surveys of what teens do
where people buy how people shop you see
gap is irrelevant they're closing stores
anyone who's watching the show go to the
mall today walk it to Banana Republic
walk into gas you could swing an
umbrella and not hit anyone what's your
price you know I haven't done enough
work to actually realize once they take
the charges for closing stores and that
what's gonna look like for the next two
to three years but I think there's no
reason why gap does not break 52 we
close so I think God will probably trade
lower than $20 within the next six
months